[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis hier on le pressentait le
festival d'avignon a officiellement été
annulés ce matin
[Musique]
actuellement pour être indemnisé une
année un intermittent doit travailler
507 heures sur les douze derniers mois
avec l'accord signé jeudi soir entre le
medef et trois syndicats minoritaires un
intermittent devra désormais avoir
effectué ses heures en dix mois pour
être indemnisé que huit mois
[Musique]
pour nous maintenant c'est aller
jusqu'au bout des choses c'est à dire de
pousser le gouvernement ne pas ratifier
les accords qui ont été signés le 26
[Musique]
ce mois de juillet une annulation du
festival une annulation simplement des
premières représentations de festival
serait une catastrophe économique ou
culturel on peut tout faire
estac le gouvernement a une part de
responsabilité avec les partenaires
sociaux et notamment les professionnels
du secteur pour que cet accord soit
améliorée en certains points
[Musique]
la grève du mercredi 8 et donc voter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je ne tient évidemment pas avoir le
public perdu au ballottés et je ne veux
pas non plus s'il s'était agi de
continuer voir étaler les divisions du
milieu théâtral sous le regard à la fois
du patronat et de l'état
donc ce festival va se clore on l'a dit
la mort dans l'âme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]